I suppose this might be a first for you as well,
but on the forest talk show in the forest. Yeah. That's for sure. I,
you know, I tried to find the perfect compromise.
So sort of wilderness and sort of studio the wilderness is for you.
The studio is for me.
It's very nice place to be. There's nothing like trees really.
And in the middle of the city, they're even more precious. Yeah.
What would you say is your favorite place on earth home? Wherever that may be,
but home. Yes. But is that a part apart from home
Europe? Because, uh, you know, I,
I don't enjoy I'm here. I'm in Scandinavia.
I should be saying it's wonderful to be cold, but, um,
I don't enjoy the cold particularly. I mean, it's bracing to a degree, but, uh,
I don't enjoy being frozen stiff. I mean,
I've been to both of the North pole and the South pole and, um,
it's a relief to come out from those temperatures as far as I'm concerned,
but equally I don't like it being boiling hot either.
So Europe's pretty good to me.
You you're here because the perfect world foundation has honored you with,
with, with, uh, uh,
price being the conservation is not there. Well,
that's very flattering, but is, is that what you,
what you identify if I, as a, as a conservationist first and foremost.
I think first and foremost, I'm a television producer.
I make television programs. Um,
but before I was a television producer, I was a zoologist, uh,
and a naturalist and the natural world means a lot to me.
And to be able to spend my life combining those two things, uh,
has been great luck. Of course, when I was studying psychology,
there wasn't any television. I mean, people say, sometimes say to me,
did you always want to be on television? I said, my dead boil go.
When I was your age, there was no television. And they'd say what? No,
no.
It was actually your, your first break was, was when they,
when they wanted to test television. Wasn't it?
That was when you got your first break in the middle?
Well, uh, I, the end of the war,
I served in the Navy for, for a couple of years and description. And I,
then I tried to work in scientific publishing,
which was extremely boring Sam's books. Uh,
and then I tried to join radio cause I'd never seen television and I
didn't get that job either. And then the people in the BBC said,
why don't you try, we've got this new thing, just starting it called television.
Would you like to try? And I said, well, why not? I mean, that was in 1952.
And, um, I, uh, uh, uh,
learn how to make Pokemons and started making programs eventually in,
in the tropics about animals.
I really to see a jungle jungle. I thought we had exciting,
quite wrong ideas. Of course,
I thought there'd be monkeys hanging from every tree and the snakes,
wherever you put foot. This isn't like that at all course. But, um,
but nonetheless, just seeing, seeing the natural world,
the richness of the lateral world, I mean, Europe's fine,
but it's not as rich as the jungle. And that's very exciting.
You you've even met animals that no longer exist.
I'm thinking about the tortilla is called, called lonesome George.
Well, he, he was, he was, uh, uh, uh,
sub species of, um, uh,
one particular group of Galapagos tortoises.
And he was at his true,
the last survivor and it was very touching to see this poor old
guy. Uh, he,
we had thought that the whole species was extinct a long time ago and then this
old tortoise in a very, very old and doddery,
you know, and he, and they found him on this one Island,
which is the one Island where, where that sub species had evolved.
And they bought him back on the China,
tried to introduce him to females of another closely related species,
but we're all George either,
whether he was just too old or whether he just thought there's not the same,
you know, not like the girls I used to them. Um,
and then one day he just here, we don't know how old he was,
but he was sitting there a hundred years old more. Yeah.
Would you say after seeing what you've seen through the years,
um, that you are, uh,
more of an optimist or a pessimist when it comes to what was
happening to the climate and to the animals?
Do you know? I,
I try and think about that question because
even if I was a pessimist,
I would still have to do everything I can possibly do to help this
current situation that we're in. I mean, it doesn't help to say, um,
Oh, we're all doomed. If you say that you say, Oh, I will forget it. You know?
And, uh, and I can't say that, um, and I am,
I am sure things are going to get worse before they get better. Uh,
but I believe they can get better. I believe sufficient of, um,
an optimist,
I suppose to think that human beings really can have,
they know, we know what has to be done. You know? Um,
the question is, we've got to convince the world that they've got to do them.
But are,
are we as a species able to work together
to go another way?
Well, we never have, well, it's not quite true. We have, um, uh,
certain sections of that, uh, of the world we have done,
we have sorted out. I mean, for example, wailing, you know, at the end,
the war, 1946, 47,
it was pretty clear that we were taking so many whales out of the ocean,
that there were some species where we can to become extinct. Um,
and, uh, the international whaling commission was set up of all countries,
including the Scandinavian countries, uh, where in fact, I mean,
it's easy for Britain to say these things.
We didn't have a big wedding industry really, but you did. Uh,
and, uh, and,
but it took 40 years before. In fact,
the nations find this at, okay, we will stop waiting with certain exceptions,
but by and large, and of course the results have been spectacular. I mean,
there are, the whales are now back in the ocean. All the species are too.
And some of them, which we thought were, were really very rare,
indeed are now in big numbers.
We have demonstrated that we can, the nations, well, we can get together. Yeah.
But this, I mean, uh, for, for, uh, to,
to save the climate,
many people would claim that we all have to change our way of life. It's uh,
it's, uh, I mean, not eating well, that's not a big sacrifice for most people.
No, that's true. But in fact,
not making money is quite a big sacrifice for people.
Cause that's what that was about.
Wasn't about what you enjoyed eating well meat. It was making money.
That was the part.
Um, have you, have you, after all you've seen and
the experience that you have, have you changed your way of life?
Are you, do you have an awareness in your daily life?
I would think so. I would hope so.
The trouble is when you get old you're young chapter, so you don't know,
but as you get old things change, the fact is that I, I,
all my life I've eaten meat until about five,
10 years ago. I still eat meat on occasion, but by and large,
I don't eat meat in the way that I did. Um,
because of your love for animals or is it no, I don't know what it is,
but I just don't. The great evil is waste. You know,
this world is a hugely rich, productive situation.
There's plenty for everybody if we don't waste it.
And it's the waste that goes on. That is so appalling. I mean,
I mean, I remember during the war, we heard stories of America,
we were all starving.
We've heard stories of American ordering huge steaks and then actually nibbling
the end of it and stubbing their cigarettes out on them render. Um, and,
and that sort of gross wastefulness. Wastefulness is the evil.
If we stop wasting things, there's plenty for everybody.
If, I mean, some people claim that
the problems are exaggerated. Uh, what would the con the,
the environment,
some people even say that the climate crisis is that it's a big hoax. Um,
the, the American president is one of them. Uh, if I was him, if,
if you sat here with him now, what would you say to him?
I dunno what I could say to president Trump. I know what I said.
I did say to president Obama and, and, and he agreed,
uh, about the problems of the world facing the, um,
it's a philosophical thing, isn't it. If you're talking about climate change,
you you've only got to look at the facts. It's very dangerous.
Look at one set of facts. I mean, if I said,
I can take to a place in, in the,
in the Antarctic where, when I first went there,
the Garcia came down to the sea and now I go look what it is now he would
equally well say, well,
there's another place on the other side of the Antarctic where it's not the soup
versus happen. If you only take one example, you're in trouble.
But if you look at the holistic statistics in an intelligence and sophisticated
way, the answer is absolutely clear. Um, and, and, um,
10 years ago, I would certainly have said that I now beginning to able to say,
just look at the facts now, just, just look at world temperatures. Now,
just look at sea temperatures. Now,
just look at the consequences of the certification with thousands of poor
people, because their lands have become totally unproductive.
But now that mixed up with politics too,
but now are crossing the Mediterranean and try to come into Europe.
See then again, they have alternative facts. That's the thing.
They have always some climate skeptic.
So there will always be a discussion. Isn't that? The big, I don't,
I think that you can't agree on, on basics. Okay.
The process advances, there are guns collapsed, progressively.
The trouble is if it's going to take so long for you to wait for
all the facts on overwhelming facts for them to convince them,
it may then be too late. That's, that's the worry.
Yeah. You've met more animals than, than most of us David. And, um,
I wonder which one did you have the best chemistry with?
I don't have chemistry with animals really, particularly. I mean, do you mean,
uh, that I could have go up and Pat.
I've seen you quite intimate with the animals.
I remember some pictures of you and some gorillas, and
you're a part of the family. No offense, but I mean, there's so much.
No, of course, but it's easy to empathize with our closest relationships,
of course, but you can't empathize, um, with, with a millipede.
And actually it's difficult to empathize with a bird who may an,
you may and try and persuade yourself that you think the same way as a or a
power thinks the same way as you and there are, as far as parents are concerned,
certain parallels, but by and large,
the more remote we are in an evolutionary sense with animals,
the less chance you have of actually communicating with them with mammos.
Yes, sure. And among mammals and primates, the monkeys and the,
and the apes. Yeah. Even, even more so.
W when I, when I see you with those gorillas,
I think about the smell
because very few people has been so close. Yes.
And that kind of animal, I just wonder how did it smell?
No, rather nice. Actually, I quite like the smell of, of primates
when they do, it's a kind of salty smell,
apes smell rather texted. I mean,
I just didn't want deal would call a particularly attractive as well.
But if you, like,
if you like gorillas or I moved on particularly alright,
lovely. I mean, really very attractive creatures.
Did, did you ever come home with some exotic diseases or something?
I came home from, from Indonesia, um,
and having been away for four months. And in those days without a contact,
you know, we had no international phones and so on. And, uh,
and I I've been traveling,
took a long time to fly back from Borneo and my eventually got home
late at night. Um, and, uh, and, uh, I went to bed,
my wife was lying alongside me and I woke up at about three o'clock in the
morning, pouring sweat. And I thought, this is it.
I mean, this is what I've read about. This is malaria, you know? And, uh,
and Marla, what do I do to our nudge and say, I've got malaria darling,
or what will I do? And I put my hand on the sheet and it was,
he was red hot almost. And I suddenly discovered that
while I've been away, my wife had bought electric blankets with dual control
and mine was still on.
So you were quite okay. I was okay.
Having, having the, the one, the lust that you obviously have, uh,
has that made you more restless? Uh, when you, when you were back in back home.
Um, I've calmed down a bit when you're in your nineties, you know, um,
I've, I've, I've, I'm so lucky what a fantastically,
lucky time I've had, you know, I've been everywhere. I really want to be,
except perhaps I would like to been to the Gobi desert. Um,
I've been on the edges of the Gabby. Does it, uh, the BBC,
the bull costing people will never send television would never send me to the
central, the Gobi because there's no animals,
but a wonderful bothers dinosaur, fast, a little passionate.
I love trying to force off.
Just not great television though.
No, no, it takes time. That's not good. And even when you find it,
it doesn't do anything spectacular.
Your, your life has been, I mean, so much traveling so much,
so many farewells, uh, it must've been,
it must've been like daily, daily life for you to say,
bye-bye I see you in four months.
Um, well, it was increasingly increasingly hard.
Um, and particularly when you have a family, uh,
saying goodbye for four months is hard. Um,
four months was as far as long as I ever went away, and then they got shorter.
And as,
as airlines became more widespread and more reliable,
you were able to get back even just quickly for Fortnite, you know,
so you could, and so the,
the four months trips began to shrink and they shouldn't the three months and
the two month now, I don't go away for more than about two weeks from time,
two or three weeks time, because wherever you go,
you can get back fairly quickly.
And also becoming 92, as you are now,
there has been some per worlds that is forever for you.
Which-which has been the most difficult for you.
Well, if, um, I mean, losing your wife is, is, um,
a traumatic and devastating experience,
um, and which, um, would cost the long shadow.
Um, um,
that's the closest loss I've had in losing your parents and losing
my brother, um, uh, is also a great shock. Richard, the filmmaker.
Yes.
You, you, you were traveling one year when your wife passed away, right?
No. Well, I, I got back in time. Well, I got him back on time.
She was in hospital. Yeah.
How did that change your life?
Um, well profoundly of course. Um,
on the other hand, the children, um,
my son and my daughter were BookBub grown up and established in their various
careers. Um, and, um,
uh, I, I'm not a very domesticated person. I'm not a, not much of a co I'm,
no sort of a cook. Uh, and, um, had I,
my daughter who was ahead of, uh, uh, primary school, uh,
had teacher, um,
eventually we're not all at quite soon came to sort me out
in terms of, of cooking one thing or another,
and she now runs the house and so
on. So that's, um,
a blessing and the God sandwich for which I'm profoundly grateful.
Um, and very, very lucky.
You're not, you're not a religious person,
but you don't call yourself an atheist either.
What do you think happens when we die?
Oh, I, I think nothing happens between
I'm working on that basis. Um, I,
I I'm,
I'm not an atheist in the sense that I say with confidence and,
and true belief that there is no, God, I think very much,
I once made a film about termites. Um, and you know,
they build these huge Hills and I took my
Chet head and cut the top off so that we could see inside and there were all
these termites or busier. Um, and, um,
I suddenly thought, you know,
they can have no idea. Then I am looking at the,
as anything else other than being, like being a termite, uh,
because they can't see above anything else. So these are,
these are blind workers,
so they don't know this is happening and it's not that they're stupid or
faithless or something, but they don't have the senses that particular sense.
And I can't help thinking there's a possibility that we don't have a particular
sentence. There may be, there is somebody out there.
Maybe there is a top of a up there,
people are looking down on us and wondering what we're doing and try and
working. You know, I don't know how can I say because I have no substance.
So I am resistant to saying pontifically
and positively without question, there is no Cod, I cannot say that.
You recently did a scene with a satellite.
Well, th th the idea was a notion that these days you can actually,
from a satellite, you can actually monitor an elephant. I mean,
using a satellite up in the miles, up in the sky,
there is now technology when a labeled you to recognize an individual elephant.
So from a, from a conservation point of view, it's a very valuable tool.
And to, uh, demonstrate this, uh, we thought we'd set up all the producer,
thought it set up above position when he rang up, uh,
got in touch with a firm that runs the satellites.
And can we book a time in which we could get a satellite shot
of our television, presented that to say me in one particular place by the,
on the banks of the Zambezi river. Um,
and so we could come down from the world and you'd see other Africa, Africa,
and then you'll see the Zambizi you go further in and renting say,
Landrover that alongside the Landrover, you'll see a person.
You could see it was me. And then you'll cut. And I would say, well,
here I am on the, but real. So that meant that you had to have a particular
to within a second. Uh, so when in fact the satellite would be there,
you had the book,
it was going to cost a lot of money in order to do this particular shot and
everything would be set up. So I want, uh, two minutes,
31 minutes and 15 seconds, you had to be there.
And as whatever time was,
the time we poached the produce was hiding under a Bush, C,
and he was coming out. And he said that, uh, two minutes ago,
then w woman is 30 to go, uh, one minute to go getting ready.
And that moment, this was on the remote as part one,
prepare a remote part of Africa on the zombie.
And Andrea was suddenly came out in the Bush and we had
45 seconds ago. And I said, go away, go, go away.
And, and, uh, a very pretty lady let out of the window and said, Oh, hi.
I said, look, I just go. And she said, it's David. I said,
I said, go see where they, the producer, the producer shot out.
Wow. She drove, it didn't know what happened. And we lost her.
Never found her again. And so she still got low. I thought, Oh,
we call it the picture. All right. So when do we get to see, I don't know.
David F neuros. Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.